bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fari j
oggi siamo su scp raga sc p penso sia il
videogame che mi avete consigliato di
più da quando faccio video in generale
me lo avete consigliato di più di tutti
soltanto che non l'ho mai fatto in vita
mia semplicemente perché andremo a
scoprirlo molto presto vabbè comunque me
l'avete consigliato in tantissimi come
al solito ogni volta che mi consigliate
un videogame vuoi alla fine finisce
sempre bene quindi vi ringrazio in
anticipo e detto questo direi di
iniziare allora andiamo su new game
direi di iniziare allora ne name devo
mettere il mio nome a che cazzo gli
serve al mio nome vabbè sacco banana va
bene bananas
ok andiamo avanti start ci siamo allora
devo che cazzo dove sono già partiamo ma
pick up the paper on the dance che non
prendi inventori bay presi in tempo ok
devo prendere sta roba devo premere tab
ok cosa mi cosa mi devo aprire perché tu
pensi che io lega sta roba
io non leggo i libretti di istruzioni
quando compro le cose e devo leggere sta
roba ma figuriamoci
buongiorno buongiorno mi dispiace non ho
preparato nulla se non ti faceva un
caffè
vabbè c'è un cesso se vuoi accomodarti
nodo uscire io bene
abuja ha anche portato degli amici
buongiorno anche a lei devo farlo
seguirci ok poi perfetto dove vi portate
segue bene vi sto seguendo siamo
pacifici
eh no sei veramente sexy mi dice hai
comprato quel cazzo di paio d'occhiali
che ti sta da dio
vabbè devo andare devo seguire the seas
fantastico perso mi stavo perdendo a
camminare all'indietro
raga quale cazzo è lo scopo di sto gioco
me l'avete consigliato in duemila ma non
so che cosa devo fare
probabilmente voi lo sapete io no quindi
state già pregustando tutto è che mi
vuoi stuprare che capisco barche a devo
andare avanti grazie minchiam i sei
veramente rassicurando brutto pezzo di
merda prima o poi ti vengo a prendere
buongiorno mi hanno anche a voi li hanno
portato qui e sono
devo entrare lì dentro
siamo sicuri buongiorno che cazzo chiude
ferma faccia puntare allora c'è un tipo
pervertito nudo al muro che si sta
strisciando e probabilmente sta anche
godendo
ebbene sia aperta di nuovo la porta io
uscirei raga io non ho capito un cazzo
succede
buongiorno io cazzo di a stuprati
ragazzo è successo oh mio dio è dio sono
morti questi ma che cazzo bene è
scappato quella fare è andato lì sopra
fatemi uscire come casa a preti
maledizione non si apre un cazzo a
questo film ragazzi sta facendo paura
sta cosa direi di andare avanti bene
porca [ __ ] ma da dove sputato quello
o mio dio
raga è no non mi piace non mi basta
voglio finirla qui cazzo è tutto così
sta roba no assolutamente
ma stiamo scherzando via via via di
quasi usami chiudi la porta porca
[ __ ] chiude
cioè io non ho capito ma di nuovo buio
porca [ __ ] non mi piace quello diventa
buio
andare avanti con ri maledizione
famiglia si può chiudere st porta si ci
può dire vai chiudiamo tutto prova a
entrare adesso brutto bastardo prova mi
prende per il culo a caso cioè a
perfetto attenzione vai entriamo mai
chiusi sotto raga io fabi blindo dentro
riguardate qua dentro si sta da dio cioè
io non riuscirei più neanche da qua eh
vabbè sono costretto ad andare avanti mi
sa se rimaniamo qui tutta la vita
bene è una stanza rossa non mi piace non
mi piace per niente ma noi entriamo lo
stesso c'è un condotto devo salire
salire nel condotto corda ma che cazzo
serve condotto cioè non ci posso mica
saltare sopra
vabbè devo andare da si è aperta questa
perfetto chiuditi che ho e detti
qualsiasi cosa va bene ma chiusi che va
bene più avanti si è tutto molto allegro
cazzo fantastico
entriamo io ormai entrò nelle porte a
caso raga deve soltanto riuscire a
trovare le porte giuste ma qual è lo
scopo visto gioco c'è deve uscire da
stop nostro posto
aiuta cazzo poi appunto ma che cazzo io
ero convinto di essere al sicuro dietro
porca [ __ ]
raga è una cosa assurda ma che cazzo di
gioco è questo ma cosa volete che ho
consigliato ma io lo sapevo c'è ormai io
ci devo perdere le speranze quando voi
vi consigliate i giochi quando voi ve li
consigliate maledizione io me ne vado
bene va via via via di qua via dico
abbia di pavia dico assolutamente via di
qua ci deve essere un altra via
maledizione per questa aperta no questa
è quella di prima chiudi chiudi ok cesta
porta che chiusa che cazzo sia aperto
via di qui addio
porca [ __ ] ma che cazzo ma non si può
va dai ma cos'è o mio dio raga sto gioco
e una cosa assurda ma chi cazzo sei
inventato sta roba che voglio capire
voglio capire a chi minchia venuto in
mente di fare un gioco del genere è una
cosa impossibile da quasi sono arrivato
non lo so non me ne frega niente andiamo
via assolutamente più di tutto da qua
non ci sono passato vai chiude perfetto
che cazzo è una camera blindata questo
amici chiudo dentro ci rimango tutta la
vita come si chiude cosa devo fare qua
dentro c'è qualcosa che posso prendere
assi ho preso qualche talk è perfetta
una radio posso cambiare canale si 12345
non funziona un cazzo allora cosa mi
dici 12345 sono funziona un cazzo raga
usciamo a ci sono cosa ho preso i
documenti che cazzo me ne faccio dei
documenti in un posto come questo io
devo leggere i documenti e li prendete
per il culo bene vado via assolutamente
via qui tutto via via via
ok ragazza a perfetto questo non l'ho
ancora visto andiamo avanti di qua è
l'unica strada quindi è questa salviamo
c'è perché ogni tanto ci sono dei buchi
sul pavimento che cazz che è passato
hulk devo andare io questa la chiudo a
prescindere non mi piace
andiamo avanti questa neanche tanto
meglio comunque c'è una tessera
c'è bisogno di una chiave per aprire la
porta perfetto devo trovare st chiave
quindi devo andare avanti
ho trovato una radio per ora che non so
che cazzo mi serve costa radio la cosa
che posso fare al massimo ascoltare
radio maria
quindi non serve a un cazzo in poche
parole andiamo avanti così
devo ci siano tutti uguali sti cazzo di
corridoi devo andare avanti di qua
e non mi sta piacendo per niente radio
mista a perfetto questa zona mi consola
tantissimo mi sembra di essere passato
nelle ambientazioni di residenti vo al
veramente fantasy che cazzo ci sono dei
gas
direi di passare all estero ma non sta
facendo male agli occhi
tra l'altro raga o letto che quella fare
lì che spunta ogni tanto
praticamente non devo non ho capito se
devo o non devo guardarlo negli occhi
perché praticamente vedete che il
personaggio principale sbatte le
palpebre quando non quando è buio cazzo
lui può apparire può apparire via chiudi
ok ok io vi amo ma cazzo più di tutto
bene quando si chiudono gli occhi
quell'affare ti compare all'improvviso e
noi non vogliamo che compaia maledizione
devo andare avanti però perché se non
vado avanti non trova la tessera era qui
maledizione chiude non si sanno
veramente sera qui al è rimasto qui
quindi dovrei lasciare aperto ma noi
chiudiamo lo stesso così chiudiamo tutto
c'è un vetro
devo sfondarlo possa aprire la porno
posso aprire la porta ma no anche qui
una chiave chiavi ovunque
devo bene salviamo io non ho capito bene
se devo guardarlo o non devo guardarlo
perché c'è una paperella di gomma che
cazzo ci faccio con una paperella di
gomma si fa anche il bagno quel tipo mi
sa
va beh devo andare di quasi vado di cuma
raga non sta mettendo un'ansia che voi
non ne avete il play ma tratto questo
non era al punto iniziale a meno che non
sia un'altra zona uguale ma penso sia
un'altra zona uguale
se infatti era un'altra zona simile che
cazzo di posto e questo cos'è code
maledizione cosa che cazzo devo fare qui
cosa un ascensore è una scelta si pensò
di sia effettivamente un codice non lo
so il codice cosa faccio
metto il codice a caso 1337 va bene no
non era quello perfetto
ok raga il codice non ce l'abbiamo
quindi per aprire quella porta
dobbiamo prima andare a meno che non si
apra concreti ma con questo si apra sul
corpo perfetto cazzo come me chiuso ma
come chiuso mi serve a ok meglio mi
chiami stavo preoccupando seminari o
sentito qualcosa andiamo su ok
portano da morire gli ascensori questi
videogame non avete idea si stiamo
salendo di sicuro perché ok fatti siamo
saliti lo zio
pensavo che fosse quel tipo di aver
aperto la porta vi giuro
salviamo perfetto sinistra o destra
ditemi voi
ok andiamo a sinistra
spero che abbiate risposto tutti quanti
sinistra sennò fatto un mega fail e
vabbè che cazzo è sta roba via cos'è
oh mio dio cosa cazzo è quella roba via
cos'era aerei in fondo tipo che cazzo
era mi sembrava tipo andiamo via
assolutamente chiuditi maledizione cure
non c'è una porta e che cazzo
cos'è una pillola cosa me ne faccio una
pillola me la infilo suo periodo è la
strada giusta vero no perché prima c'era
quel tipo non voglio che mi sfuggì
lavanda
mente aiuta apriti che cazzo ma che mi
spiegate che cazzo è quella roba dove
sono che cazzo succede ora
cosa sta succedendo cosa cazzo succede
non ci capisco più niente
vabbè ragazze devo essere sincero non ho
capito che cosa c'è che cosa è successo
fino adesso direi di finirla qui per
questo episodio
anche perché adesso di sicuro ci sarà
tutta altro da fare
abbiamo praticamente appena iniziato
questo ragazzo per oggi è tutto finisco
qui veramente è una roba assurda non
avevo mai c'era un motivo se non avevo
mai giocato a sta roba
avete capito adesso perché va beh io
direi veramente richiuderla qui perché
sto sudando cazzo migliore una cosa
assurda dei video vi è piaciuto lasciate
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi invece vediamo al
prossimo video bene ragazzi